what do you love about Philippe
you got me man I you know it's it's you
need answers
what do we have leavin [ __ ]
do you have the cute girls that drive
around with the beer carts though and IQ
they're all okay what do you like about
Cleveland well for one thing culturally
it's really tops yeah this is one of the
fifth largest parades in the nation that
was a giant size you know it's over
John it is
hang on
and I guess the final question then is
earnest Byner what's the first word that
pops into your head
you know what he gets a lot of flack for
that fumble but I tell you if it weren't
for earnest Byner we never would have
been in any in a position for the drive
in a position for the fumble what about
Bernie Kosar Bernie Kosar oh he's great
he kid me that sidearm delivery that I
mean the ugliest most effective passer
and in a Ferrari afraid he had a moment
of silence yeah a moment of silence
served Bernie Kosar
trampled by Cozart and the Browns also
cleaned that seven-point lead